good morning everyone ah so my name is
David it's a pleasure to be here coming
from st. Thomas University as a
university of miami south Floria i would
like to present today about a work that
was done along with two of my students I
have them here sitting and the
motivation for that class for this
presentation was a class that we taught
last spring about graph theory and
networks as part of the mayor of
mathematics and we were thinking about
what sort of project can we give to
students to do a course project at the
end of semester so we divided a class in
different teams and one of the teams in
that class was dedicated to the use of
graph theory in biomedical applications
one of the applications that we use it
was the application to brain networks
and
oh sorry I don't know what's going on
here with
one of the applications we found
interesting was the application to brain
science using graph theory so that's the
reason why i will divide my talk pretty
much into what the subject of the
analysis which is epilepsy and then what
are the technique that allow you to get
information from and how to use a graph
theory and in that context how you can
implement that we're using Mathematica
okay so epilepsy in general is a
condition is in your Oracle condition
which is characterized by seizures that
people experience sometime those
seizures might be mild some time those
seizures might be extremely dangerous to
the point that people might just get
completely out of motion out of out of
business it's Apple absence is the
fourth most common neurological
condition in the United State that's the
reason why it's a lot of grant from the
NIH oriented to treat the problem or
deal with the problem of epilepsy but
from the medical point of view epilepsy
is a big challenge for medical doctors
for two reasons there are some epileptic
seizures that might be treated with
medications and patient can manage the
condition but there are some epileptic
seizures that can now be treated with
medication and patient have to be
exposed to surgical procedures then when
surgeon have to do the surgical
procedures the percentage of success on
those surgical procedures are pretty low
why because data are is usually is a war
of doctors sitting together and they try
to guess what the best strategy to
remove pieces of the brain to try to
keep the epilepsy under control some
time they're lucky and they might make
that and patient are recovering pretty
well sometimes they're returning of the
epilepsy to the patient is becoming even
worse than the procedure before the
procedure
so that's the reason why graph theory
now is trying to help in that direction
trying to figure it out what are the
functional networks involved during the
epileptic seizures and I'm given a
guidance to the medical doctors when
they have to do surgical procedures what
part of the brain should be eliminated
in order to minimize the invasive
procedure that that involved okay which
are the two technique from where we're
getting let's say experimental values
okay one is the electron to follow grams
so you got the time series of elections
or follow grams and you can pair
electrons to follow ram from the resting
state or with those that you have during
seizures so then you have a reference
normal a legend Sir Followgram and then
you have what you call the partial
seizures patient a half epileptic show
it epilepsy with a mild component and
then you have epileptic patients that
are extremely chronic that are showing a
berry are as ice showing here as showing
a very chaotic signal in those cases and
that's why you called your generalized
seizures because then the epileptic wave
spread out over the entire brain is not
very localized this is spreading out
over the entire brain so typically what
is the procedure that people follow you
have the electrons of Followgram that
has a pretty good temporal resolution
and you complement the
electroencephalogram with a functional
MRI the reason why people choose
functional MRI because functional MRI is
oriented toward the oxygen content of
the blood and then the oxygen content of
a blood is an indication to proxy
indication of their brain activity so a
functional MRI has a pretty good spatial
resolution in contrast to electrons of
allah granda has a pretty good temporal
resolution so if you want to get the
best of both war people try to combine
electrons to follow ram to get a
a good temporal resolution with the fMRI
to get a pretty good spatial resolution
so once you have that with that kind of
resolution the question is what kind of
information can we get out of this okay
typically the patients are getting
together the elections of Followgram and
the fMRI and then you try to contract
what you call the connection or the
connectivity matrix how it is done okay
this is a kind of three key moment
pinky okay
because you need to elaborate on a
strategy to consider which pieces of a
brain are more connected than others so
then you are using what you call the
covariance matrix so you look for the
correlation coefficient but now when you
use the correlation coefficient the
Pearson correlation coefficient
typically covariance matrix you need to
set a threshold value for strong
correlation the other point that you
will include in your connection matrix
typically the connection matrix is done
based around correlation values higher
than a point 55 so it's just strong
correlation the one that you keep then
low correlation typically you are
putting that in the background and
you're not considering then in the first
run of your analysis so now you got a
connection matrix you might convert that
connection matrix to the adjacency
matrix which is the one that you used to
control the network and that network
could be of two type either and
anatomical network which usually we're
getting from the functional MRI or you
can have a functional network that mean
no all the note you have in the
anatomical network are participating in
the functional network so and then you
have to make that differentiation that's
the approach that we call top bottom
approach you get the information from
patients and then you will contract all
the anatomical thing in our case we
decided to adopt a bottom Top approach
so we're using mobile networks and we
will try to figure it out how the
topology of the network it influencing
the synchronization of the neuronal
oscillator or neuronal network in
general and doing this we divided the
the modeling part in two pieces a
microscopic modeling when you have newer
on your own interaction and for near on
your own interaction we use the fee
heussner human model which is pretty
common in a neuroscience and then form
all in different patches of the cortical
area of the bra
we're too many neurons are participating
simultaneously we're using the current
model mole which is a pretty typical a
model in mathematics for tuning and
synchronization and people who are
familiar with this extra God book on
dynamic dynamical system and chaos
that's one of the mole that he analyzed
a lot so we're following the bottom top
approach and doing that so what the step
of the morning that we decided to do so
okay we're creating an AMOLED Network we
look to topological indices of that
network and then based on the
connectivity matrix and the weight of
connections were passing that to the
system of differential equations and
then we compute the solution and the
synchronization processes that you have
there okay the madam madam madam attic
implementation is basted our generation
of a random graph we're using sometimes
the barabási autograph distribution the
wastrel graph distribution the Bernoulli
distribution and some other random
distribution that we created on our own
okay these are pretty much the network
that we analyze it during that process
of modeling okay the first we started
testing the situation with two neurons
and then we move it from two to ten year
runs 11 around 13 around 64 neurons and
the largest system that we molded neuron
your own interaction with with 128
neurons involved which is a pretty good
number especially when you're looking
for areas of the brain when you do the
surgical procedures as you can see some
of the networks over there they have
rich points bridgepoint are pretty
important because in graph theory we
know that Hamiltonian paths Illyrian
paths are pretty sensitive to the bridge
point because you can make the graph
disconnected and to disjoin a part of
the graph will mean that the lack of
synchronization between pieces of a
brain okay so the solution for the huge
nagumo model in a single neuron which is
the test of one is showing the limit
cycle and that's the part i'm at the
phase plot for their soul
at making sure that we're working in the
with the real mole and we tested then we
tested for the tuning around you can see
the the solution for each one of the
neurons they're following the same
pattern and then when you compute in
that case the synchronization index for
Danny Ron's you're going to see that the
synchronization index will be pretty
sensitive to the parameters of the
equation that I show where before then
we move it to the T neurons when you go
to the tenarans
connected between themselves so what
happened so you're going to see that
some of the neurons are oscillating very
fast but then you have kind of a
transient behavior where all the neurons
start dying now and the signal that you
saw the stimuli that you put in front
outside so they're going to die pretty
quickly so there's not sustained
oscillation for the particular topology
that we choose however when you look at
another topology like this one okay what
you can see there is that practically
there is no oscillation at all there's
there's some group of neurons if they
will be connected back in that way
you're not going to see too much
oscillation over their side you're not
going to see the spread out of the
stimulator where there is a kind of a
hint inhibition process over there so
now we probably with Tessa with a
64-year run configuration because we got
from near anatomy that there is some
kind of bundle of neurons that they try
to form then the right pattern what kind
of bridge in the middle and when you
look at that type of topology you will
see that the sustaining oscillation will
last for a long period of time which
means that the brain areas are connected
and I'll synchronize it and there's more
typical a nap anatomical topology that
you can see from the brain configuration
so how we implemented that in
Mathematica so or basically we work with
the adjacency matrix command the
mathematica has we created with a couple
of table to assign the way to each one
of the edges of a graph we created a
combined it matrix that is a
multiplication for the adjacency matrix
time the wait for that particular edge
and then we solve that system of
differential equation in that case is 64
near on so it's gonna be 64 different
equation in Houston aguma because you
have to valuable you are
be so it's going to be pretty much 128
equation that you solve simultaneously
and on top of that if you are that the
weight of the edge which means how
strong might be the connection between
neurons can evolve over time so you're
going to add a third equation x 64 so
that's the number of equations i use
solving simultaneously the time of
operation or the time of the time of
solution it takes in mathematica 10.3 no
more than two minutes to make the
calculation so if you do that up to
optimize away 2 minute take the solution
of all these equations for the Cure
motor model we follow a pretty much the
same idea we just change the system of
differential equations and then we look
at a different configuration now in the
cortical area the cortical area is very
different because the cortical neurons
are various parts so there's no many
neurons on the cortical area most of the
new neurons are underneath the cortical
area so the most dense configuration we
use it that the reason why we use the
fusion alguma and therefore the current
modem all we use it a more sparse
configuration but you can see that in
the first case that we use the bar Abbas
the auger distribution does the
distribution showing power low back
vertex distribution which means a
fractal distribution self-organization
the synchronization of all the solutions
are pretty evident then when you move to
another type of distribution with the
same number of nodes which is pretty
interesting 30-6 know with power low and
36 know with the what straw gas
distribution looked at now the the level
of synchronization is now going to be as
well as the one that we obtain it for
the first case we tested that sort of
configuration and that configuration we
test them because it was very typical
when you have a plea to a conclusion
that athlete get kind of hit and in
their head so there's part of the rain
again in this
connected and as a one of the network
use it very common for conclusion in
neuroscience so you can see there that
there's some oscillation that appears at
a very low level why there is always an
oscillation that is skyrocketing over
there which is a very interesting from
the point of view of what we did it so
then we tested the Bernoulli
distribution for the photograph with
that sort of configuration and we found
that that configuration doesn't show
kind of a very typical behavior on the
brain
uh-uh an oscillation
in amplitude why the rest of the
oscillations are pretty much limited to
certain amplitude that is control at
over time finally the cure motor motor
would solve it for 46 neurons highly
interconnected so the highly
interconnected neurons is showing a
perfect graph when you look at the
oscillations and that's an indication
that the lower connectivity of the brain
is very very important when you are
addressing prana like epilepsy so if you
change in the level connectivity at the
local scale so that will immediately
impact the response of the group of
neurons in conclusions both mathematical
models for the dynamic of interacting
neurons were saw a show in sign of
synchronization the order parameter
which quantified the strain of the
synchronization wasn't calculated this
time sensitivity to the strain of
connectivity of networks appears of one
of the most striking features and the
study was limited to synaptic
connections that do not change over time
shrine of the connection remains
constant this limitation might miss the
fact that synaptic connections either
improve all deteriorate over time
leading to central nervous system
disorders in this case it was controlled
by the connectivity a comparison with
the real epileptic brain networks
obtained in front AG umber singh no
processing is planning for the future
the result of da simulation was polish
already in open science for him and is
already a peer reviewer that I included
there the the reference and I'm very
pleased to have my both student here
that they conducted most of the
simulations results that's it thank you
you